その他質問などございませんか？ すいません
お願いします はい あの
先ほどおっしゃった十四の不善心情というのがありましたけど
その中で私は基本ベースとして
情交 怒り 混乱というものがあると思うんですけど
あの欲でウキウキしている時も
怒りでカーッとなってる時も
必ず混乱っていうのがあると思うんですけど
それは正しいですか  あの
この不善心情の組み合わせっていうのは決まってます
だからもうアビダンマテキストをこれから書きますから
そこら辺にその組み合わせはあると思います
で 我々そう感じるんですけど
そうでない場合もあります
えーちょっと待って あのパーリ語で思い出さないともう出てきませんだからどう出てくる
まあ常光無知などは基本だから
まあ大体はある場合はあります
で 怒りとかの場合はぎゅっと心固めるんだから
まあ常光はない可能性もあります
あの 何でも一緒ということでもないんです
一応無知があって 無知の上で怒りに関わる心情が起こるか
欲に関わる心情が起こるか
無知 自分だけで頑張るかということなんですね
例えば 欲の心に欲がある
無知がある 無知っていうのはモハでって
うん ちょっと今そこのことちょっと思い出せませんですけどね
あの 我々にとってはなんか混乱しているという気持ちはあると思いますよ
ただ 欲がある時でも なんか落ち着いてないというかね
これはあります なぜならば
無知だから欲が生まれたんだから
常光は無知の仲間ですね
怒りもまあが出てくると
当然興奮して混乱する
判断できなくなっちゃうしね
そうすると無知がどうしても必要なんです
いくつかの組み合わせはあります
それはアビダンマテキストで組み合わせはまあ丁寧に出します
はい はい もうはい  今お話しいただいた中で
ブッダの教えを持っていれば安全であるというお話だったんですけども
あの最低限私は長老のお話だとかの中で
まあブッダの教えを知って
それで守って安全に生きていきたいと思うんですけれども
その長老とお会いしてお話を聞いたりするのは
毎日ではないので ブッダの教えの
まあ長老がお話ししていただけない他のブッダの教えをその知るには
どういったような方法で手に入れてはよろしいでしょうか
一応ブッダの経典日本語訳もされているでしょうにね
そういうところでしょうね
あまりこの人が自分の意見ばっかりブッダの教えとして並べ替えるとところは
もう我々もすごい気をつけるんですね
ブッダの教えについて語る場合は
その人の考え方だからね
しかし その中でもいいところはいっぱいあるしね
安全なのは直接ブッダの教えをそのまま訳で読むことなんですよ
随分明確に言ってますからね
で 日常生きている場合はどうしようか
心配だな どうしようかなと困っている時は
この場合はブッダなら何言うでしょうかとね
ちょっと考えちゃうと
もうすぐブッダならこれやめろと言うでしょうとわかりますから
危険はなくなっちゃうんです
自分でやりたいんだけど
ちょっと不安があって
じゃあこういうことをブッダなら何言うでしょうかねと言っちゃうと
ブッダならものすごく怒るでしょうとわかりますよ
だったらもうやめる なぜならば
私の生きる哲学はいくらなんでも仏教だからということで
今までものすごい安全に生きてきましたし
これからもブッダの教えが人生哲学になると
もう世界は完全安全ですよ
人殺しもなくなるし 異常なことも全部なくなるし
自然災害 異常現象起こりませんと言っています
それぐらいすごい力ですよ
心理の力っていうのは
はい  そんなところで はい
えーと 先日 あの随談学んだ大僧正がお亡くなりになりまして
お悔やみをお祈りしたいと思いますけれども
大僧正がですね   体に今掲載されている
えーと 翻訳集をして掲載されている中にですね
さらっとですけども あの大僧正の言ってる中で
人生では自分が思っていることを引き寄せる傾向があるとおっしゃっているんですけれども
これと同じようなことは長老も今連載している沙門果経の中で
最初の頃の方におっしゃったと思うんですけれども
これをまあ近代のキリスト教徒がある程度パクって
そのクリスチャンサイエンスという考え方を作ったようなもんですけども
えーと まあ大変なんかこれは仏教心理学の深いところのものがあるんで
なかなか説明は大変だと思うんですけれども
その辺のその真実というか
新しいところはどういうものなのかというのをちょっと教えていただきたいんですが
今引用した文章をもう一度ちょっと言ってください
はい えーと 大僧正は これ日本語訳ですけれども
人生では自分が思っていることを引き寄せる傾向がある
うん うん どういう意味かあんまりわからないんですけどね
まあちょっと原文では
まあもちろん僕 まあ一般的な仏教のことをね
まあもっとわかりやすく語ってますからね
だから自分が思ったことは引き寄せるかもしれませんだけど
それで失敗する場合っていうのはほとんどでしょうにね
だからブッダの教えが人生論だったら
そこでちょっと一つ一旦停止して考えちゃうんですね
自分が思ったことに 我々貪瞋痴だからろくなこと思わないんですよ
我々が思うことっていうのは
結局自分を破壊しちゃうし
不幸になっちゃうんですよ
だから宗教 ブッダが教えたってもやりたくはないしね
難しいと思ったりもするし
だから難しいのは当たり前だから
人間で悟ってないんだから
煩悩があるんだからね
そう簡単にうまくいくわけじゃないんだけど
いや それでも私の哲学はブッダの
私の人生の哲学はブッダの教えですよと
いうふうにしておけば
自分が何か思って そこに引き寄せるために心が変わっていっても
あら ちょっと待ってください
ブッダならどうするのかと
と思っただけでも安全方向に行くんです
時々質問される時でも
あまりにもしつこい質問になってくると
私はすぐ自分の頭で答えようとしちゃうんですよ
ちょこっと 学問っぽいでもいろいろなんか知識っぽくなっちゃうと
自分も学問知識の方に入ろうとしちゃうんですよ
すると話が終わらなくなっちゃうんですね
私はすごい狂暴になっちゃうんで
その場合は だからすぐ読めるんだから
相手が研究しているところはこういうこういうところで
相手はミスっているところはこういうこういうところだとかね
これっていうのはすごく厳しくて狂暴なの
その瞬間で 私は瞬間でブッダならどう答えるのかと自分に聞くんですよ
聞いた途端 すごい滑らかな答えが出てくるんです
だからそういうことでものすごく守られてますよ
でなきゃ こんな大胆にね
人を馬鹿にして喋るわけでもないでしょうに
[笑い]これ自分の意見だったらもうとっくに殺されてますけどね
[笑い] やっぱりブッダのことを言ってますから
自分自分の言語かもしれません
自分の表現かもしれませんだけど
仲間はブッダのものだから
もう守られますよ 悪いことにはならない
そういうことだから 本当にものすごい見事にブッダには守られます
それにはこの参詣するということも同じ意味ですよ
人生哲学はブッダに委ねる
委ねる 委ねると 我は知ったことじゃないんだということなんです
そういうことで考えた方がいいと思います
はい  ありがとうございます
はい  僕もそうなんですけど
やる気を出す時に 例えばこういう休日とか休んだりするんですけど
いい休み方というのはありますか？例えば怠けと区別するんで
どういった休み方がいい
それは休みはどのように使うかという
休みは有意義に使うってことでしょ
いつでも有意義という一言葉ですよ
だから １ 秒でも無意味に行っちゃうと悔しくて苦しいんですよ
気持ち悪いんですよ だから休み時間は有意義にするためにどうすればいいかということですよ
そうなってくると 正しい休み方は出てくるんです
例えば休みといっても
この何もしないでいることっていうのは不可能です
それ我々時々勘違いするんで
休みだから朝から晩まで寝るぞっていうのはね
これは休みになりません
寝ることも有意義な仕事にならなきゃいかんですよ
ここまでやりましたし
もう体がクタクタ疲れているし
じゃあこの時点で寝た方がいいという風になってくると
すごい気分よく有意義的な気分で寝られます
だからこの人生は止まらない
だから休みという言葉は普段やっている仕事と違った何かやることなんです
その場合は自分で判断して何かできますからね
仕事ではできないでしょうね
だから仕事を 1 週間やると 1 日休みくれるんですよ
1 週間奴隷扱いされているんだからね
それで日曜日休みだということは
もう奴隷解放でしょ それで初めて
じゃあ自分のためになること
自分の判断で自分に有意義なことをする
何か set やると また月曜日は元気なんです
何もしないで寝ちゃうと
月曜日っていうのは最悪なんですよ
アメリカではよくある話で
一番最悪の日は何なのかというと
みんな言うのは月曜日だと
休んできてくるんだからね
もう仕事には乗れないんですね
それっていうのは正しく休んでないんです
日曜日はクタクタ悪いことばっかりして
で 時々朝まで悪いことをやったりして
もうすぐ仕事に走らなくちゃいかんですよね
もう仕事できないんですね
だからこの私は学校に行った時代では
まあ今も自分の国では土日両方休みですよ
一番楽しい日っていうのは金曜日ですね
[笑い] 明日から休みだよって
で その 2 日間は自分で考えて行動できる
まあ子供だからろくなことをやらなかったんですけど
まあ我々大人はやっぱりこの休み時間というのは自分でやりたい
有意義なことに使うと
それで月曜日はすごい元気なんです
それが正しい休み方なんです
休まないことなんで 結局
ありがとうございました
はい 友人から中道についてちょっと教えてくれって話されたんですけれども
あの経典でいいエピソードの教があったら教えていただけます
中道について  中道について教えてくれてくれたんですけれども
なんかお経でそういういいエピソードもありましたら
うーん この人何聞きたがっているかわかりませんだけどね
前回の経典解説 前回の経典解説の解説も中道に話ありましたね
なんか楽器を強すぎるような
それがいいんでしょうね
しかし 中道 2つですよ
だからブッダ 仏教そのもの
全部中道なんですよ 道ではなくて
何でしたっけ？え？だからなんかその日本語の単語を作りましたけど
え？また別な中世かな
え？ニュートラルじゃなくて
この前の講演で一応単語を一つ作りましたけど
中世 教えはすべて中って感じはなんでしたっけ？ 中道の中って書いて正しい
うん 中と正しいという中世
ニュートラルというくだらんものじゃないんで
とんでもないんです で
中世で教えはすべて中世で
実践は中道で 中道では八正道に決まってます
それであの あの えっと
あの この間経典で出てきたあの
それでいいと思いますよ
あの楽器の調整の仕方
だから中道っていうのは
まあ一応結果主義でもあってね
ノーリス主義でもあるしね
やるだけでは意味がないということでもあって
結果出るようにと 何でもかんでも良い結果出るように良い結果出るように調整して調整してずっといかなければいけないんですね
だから中道っていうのは
まあ 1発で決めるものじゃなくて
ずっと もう正しく生きることは誰でも中道ですよ
例えば立派に運転できるということは
中道ということ スピード出しすぎでもないし
ゆっくりのんびりでもないし
まあいろんなものを判断しながら判断しながらやらなくちゃいけないんですね
運転のようなもんなんですよ
あのエピソード使ってください
あのはい  はい 精進と精進することと
執着することとの ちょっと精進が執着になってしまいそうな不安もあるんですけども
どんなことにそういう時に気をつけたら
どういうふうに気をつけたらいいのか
その教えをいただきたいんですけども
あの 正しく精進するならば
そんな余裕がないんですよ
執着する余裕がね 調整することで大変でも面白くてね
精いっぱいでね あの執着しちゃうと精進できなくなるんですね
はい だから例えば目的があって目的に執着するって場合いたと思いますけど
こちらで言ったら目的を忘れなさいよと
あの過程にしなさい 過程はどうしても執着するもんじゃないでしょ？過程っていうのはやって終わったら次にですから
だから過程に集中すると執着がなくなっちゃうんです
目的を気になると執着が出てくる可能性あります
目的を気にするとできない
もうもう仕事できんですよ
達しない だから目的は置いておいて
まあそのうちもうのことやということ置いておいて
過程に集中する 過程っていうのはもうずっと変わっていくものでしょ
今日の仕事をしたら もう明日は明日の仕事だからね
それで執着が機能しなくなるんです
過程に気をつけておくと
うん はい あと 1個あればいいんです
あるならば では処理しましょう
向こうの向こう僧の三宝に帰依し
彼のもとに慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって成仏の道と
神々 先祖 祖先 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の人々そして生き物にも回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての人々そして生き物が幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱を得られますように
サッビーティオーイワンジャントーサッブロウゴーウィナッサトーマーケーバワットワンテラーヨースキーディーガーユコーバワーバワトゥサッバマンガランラックカ
ントサッバデバタサッバブッダヌバーヴェーナサッバダンマヌバーヴェーナサッバサンガーヌバーヴェーナサダーソッティバワントゥテーアビワダナシーリスセニッチ
ャンワッダパチャイノーチャッタルーダンマワッダンティーヤーユワンノー スカンバラン
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ
では 本当に長い時間どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございました